thank you
we live by this we die by this we don't
surrender we don't retreat every man
must search his own soul every time I
really soul-searching with yourself
getting with yourself sitting along with
yourself and working through them
psychological traumas emotional traumas
I'm a general so I'm always on the front
line as a general but I got to be able
to look at each one of my soldiers and
see what they need whether it be
psychologically whether it be helping
them with emotional intelligence to
navigate their emotions whether it be to
show them how to nurture themselves
whether it be to show them how they
exhibit that confidence and find that
confidence in themselves I got to be
able to look at whatever need that it is
and it's beautiful that God allowed me
to go through all of these things
because I'm a greater blessing I embrace
the things that happen to me in my past
with a sense of positivity I replace
that negative emotion attached to it
with a positive emotion and I'm grateful
for everything that happened
you love yourself
cause I love myself so if you don't love
yourself how you gonna be able to love
me properly so many men that have been
through that kind of all day every day
and I made a space in a safe place for
me and to be able to start healing a
masculinity don't have to be toxic it
can be sacred you can love yourself so
much and not when I look at people in
their eyes I see myself of different
versions of myself and me being a
nurturer if I could Aid and assist you
along your journey then cool if I can't
then cool just sometime me being able to
just give you a look up I understand
what you're going through just speaking
to somebody could change their day
that's a cry for help when you see
somebody going to the gym three four
times a day something not right with him
but something wasn't right with me and
as men we'll go to the gym and just kill
ourselves and hurt ourselves in the gym
to keep from hurting somebody else it's
a lot of men that suffering silence they
come up to me they hug me in the gym
they cry right there when they see me
when you say suffer in silence do you
know how powerful that is we do it's a
lot of us that suffer in silence I'm the
one who's trying to take my own life I'm
the one who said these things so other
people understand it's okay to feel like
this but this is the way that I I
changed it around I take all of that
negative emotional energy and I put it
and I turn my pain in a passion I put it
into something that better serves me and
Humanity I worked hard for these results
I suffered I went through the fire
adversity builds character
I wouldn't give it up God bless the dead
cause I ain't gonna give it up I gave
him all and I ain't getting nothing from
it Gotta Be Love I'm up and rank and I
ain't push one button we we had it with
faces I ain't getting uncovered I know
they still trying to get something
punished this is me being triggered like
this emotionally where does this stem
from so it always takes me going back
was it of a time in my life where my
mama or somebody in the family made me
feel like I wasn't seen or made me feel
like I wasn't good enough or made me
feel like I wasn't worthy like you'd be
like he's so cold-hearted it's not that
we co-hearted but we know it's all a
matter of time before we go back to jail
so I can't even love my children like I
want to I can't get close to my wife
because when I go to jail I don't want
to be in there stressing about them I
went on Mike Tyson and talked about me
and him shared a a story about us both
being molested like I'm the only rapper
that living a truth ain't nobody living
in a truth I'm gonna preach to you with
my actions when I utter with my mouth my
actions must prove and the greatest
teachers teach when I was speaking and
that's just always been my philosophy
cause I'm still learning and one of my
biggest lessons is I'm learning to love
the stranger that was once myself my
mind don't even think prison because
I've mastered it in the facility I go to
I'm going to be in a leadership position
because I know how to do that that's not
nothing that's this child's play to me
the hardest thing is to can you come out
here from nothing
and be greater than what you was before
if you being factual like I said I'm not
the richest man in the world I'd have
been broke most times and I'd have been
Rich I'd have lost way more fights than
I'd have won but I won the ones that
count when you met me you never saw me
wear jewelry my brother died and I only
wear diamonds cause Mazzy he loved
jewelry the beautiful blessing about
growing up poor is you did not really
experienced and dealt and lived with
every type of behavior pattern that you
won't ever deal with in life yeah man at
an accelerated pace so you wasn't
shielded from the real world that's the
beauty and growing up poor or growing up
in poverty you already dealing with
everything so you already know how to
navigate it ain't been a time that I
wasn't scared or I didn't how I feel
it's okay to have feelings but I operate
and I face that fear with bravery take
us always recognize guilt Boom the
hardest thing for me to do was to set
boundaries and say no and and this is
the year that I've been putting the
energy back into myself for the first
time in my life I had to make other
people feel uncomfortable because misery
loves company
anybody I saw in shape I had to make it
not cool to be in shape I had to make it
not cool to look good I was miserable
I was the most negative person to be
around I wouldn't want to be around me I
was negative everything I do is emulated
so I am new I was chasing something that
I already have the law of limited states
that whenever two opposing forces cannot
come to an agreement unless I always
rules the greater and you know I come as
I am I don't drink no more I don't smoke
no more I go to the gym I don't have no
security I am free
a lot of people out there that's really
want to do the right thing
but they put too much on themselves I
did the small stuff the little things
add up to the big things like you start
smile and work your way like anybody
that would say get into fitness I start
out walking and drinking water I
wouldn't even change my day every year
in life right now
the right path you where you're supposed
to be don't rush it slow and steady
anything slow people show anything fast
don't leave just you having that
intention to want to make those changes
anything that go on in the body is
energy yeah we are energy we can take
that energy translated and transform it
into what we needed to transform into
right it's just about knowing Faith
isn't something that you just think and
believe right it's that it's that it's
that substance in your heart where you
know man I know I can beat it this is
the first time I can say I've been proud
of myself a lot of my results came from
um beating myself up being hard on
myself and I guess that was you know
that was a way of like um
dealing and working through like a
traumatic past and I just got to the
point where I'm able to laugh at myself
I just I'm I'm back able to stand up and
do it from a standing position you know
you do it on your knees but I'm able to
stand up I was doing that first but I
had kind of ripped one of my ab muscles
my body wasn't ready
I was doing it prematurely so now I'm to
the point where I could do it like
standing up and when I was doing it at
the gym I had kind of like slipped a
little bit and I laughed at myself yeah
it sound good to be able to laugh at
myself and not be embarrassed and not
care about what other people think so
for the first time I really been like
happy and I've been I've been cautious
of what I speak to myself like my
biggest expert Muhammad Ali I'm gonna
show you how great I am he suffered
he's suffered
they made it hard for him
but he smiled he found a way to smile
through it all
yeah he suffered he died doing what he
loved and I had really had put it in my
mind like this music I love it I'm gonna
dive
I love it I can't I can't stop but die
for this I love it that much I'm gonna
die for it when a man meets his mission
him and his mission become one I'm gonna
die for this but when you live in your
spirit and in truth you make all of the
wrong people uncomfortable anyway so hey
hey I wasn't made for everybody to like
you once you change your perspective
that's when miracles happen it was a
blessing for me because I gained a
greater understanding of myself
I don't have to engage with the world I
create my own world around me
foreign